and uh i couldn't bring my my polarized
sunglasses here so i brought these
actual polarizers here so if you take
this and put in front of your telescope
there
you have now made a polarimeter you have
made a polarization sensitive telescope
now you may not be able to immediately
know how you would use such a thing but
one way to think about now take this guy
and look at a light look at a light
source put one up to your eye and now
put the other one in front of it
anywhere and now rotate them
what happens to the light source
it becomes brighter and dimmer and
brighter and dimmer yeah so it's called
a quadrupolar pattern right so it's
repeating it goes bright dim bright dim
uh
it double rotates twice in intensity for
every single physical rotation
and that's because of the property of
the photon the photon is a spin one
field but the polarization of light is
it's the axis at which its electric
field is oscillating its electric field
is marching straight up and straight
down and so therefore vertical
polarization is the same as negative
vertical polarization and so you get the
same pattern as you rotate two times for
every one physical rotation it's just
like a spin a spin two
object so now if you put that in front
of the telescope
you can do one of two things now you're
polarizing all the light that's going in
because you have one of the polarizers
and then you can analyze it as you
rotate the other one you can analyze it
and change the amount of polarization
or you can put this kind of very special
crystal in here there's a crystal it's
called calcite this is from lex luthor
not lex friedman this crystal put it on
top of your printed notes there and tell
me what does it look like
there's uh
like i could see everything twice it's a
double image it's a double image that is
a special crystal that has two different
indices of refraction
so light emerging which is unpolarized
from the black ink comes out
and it splits into two different
directions and it could split even more
if i made the crystal give you my more
expensive crystal but that's all i have
what is the crystal with this kind of
property called it's called calcite this
is crystal it's called birefringent
crystal bi means two refrigerant means
refracting
so this is a special type of material
that
separates light based on its
polarization pretty clean
by signal yeah it's it's cleanly
too
yeah see i'm seeing two very cleanly
it's very crisp right so that's that's
yours to keep with every time you host
me now take the polarizer underneath
your left hand uh yep put it on top of
the crystal
and kind of move it back and forth wow
this is incredible you can switch as you
rotate you switch from one
signal to the other so it's one of the
refractions to the other
whoa so that is now you are analyzing
the polarization you are confirming the
light comes out of the crystal two
different types of polarization
and effectively what we do is we have
those two things if you like but working
in the microwave so our detect that's
where this the cosmic photons are
brightest in the microwave regime in the
electromagnetic spectrum and we're
coupling that to a refracting telescope
but your eyes are refracting telescopes
so you are a polarimeter right now
the human eye can actually slightly
detect polarization um but otherwise it
mainly detects its intensity of light
and the color that's what we call color
and intensity brightness so you're
devising a
instrument that's very precisely
measuring that problem exactly and doing
so in the microwave region with
detectors not made of uh biological
human eyes retina cells but of
superconductors
and uh things called balometers and and
this has to be done at temperatures
close to absolute zero under vacuum
conditions one billionth of the pressure
we feel here at sea level
you